[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash babies we are starting now and
thank you for tuning in
it's Tuesday we started we're doing the
pockets on Tuesday today because we flew
back yesterday from I don't even know
where I was I was in Spokane did some
shows over there and some shows in
Seattle but we are back now in Los
Angeles for a few days before we head on
out to you know the Toronto ish area
Hamilton we go to Windsor and st. Louis
is the rescheduled show that is now sold
out and Kalamazoo which why did you name
it that way but it's all sold out and
everything's great and we added some
shows in Sioux Falls I think and Fargo
why the [ __ ] am I going there huh but
I'm going I don't know this tour I was
just like [ __ ] I want to go everywhere
and also I'm in the bag unit so I'm
trying to [ __ ] fill up those bags you
know when you need somebody to fill up
some bags you call the bag unit that's
what you [ __ ] call and I'm the leader
of the bag unit so uh I had some
allergies this past weekend I don't know
if it was uh I don't think I actually
got sick but I get you know I get a lot
of sleep I try to get a lot of sleep if
I miss a night of sleep I get sick it's
as simple as that if I miss a night of
sleep I get sick I got two hours of
sleep one night because one of the
flights was at 4:00 a.m. or some [ __ ]
and I got sick picture that and other
stuff goes wrong too when I'm asleep man
sleep I think is the number one thing
that you need period it cures all I lose
sleep I get [ __ ] I get sick I got a
[ __ ] ingrown hair on my neck and that
doesn't hurt yes is a pinkish [ __ ] yeah
did I already cut my beard so you can
see it extra well yes and is it annoying
oh yes it is
should I do I wish that I knew that I
was getting an ingrown hair before I
trim my beard yes they haven't know is
it fine yeah
isn't my life okay yeah but it's still
annoying babies yeah so we had great
shows in Seattle it was raining everyone
there should move because of the weather
is so [ __ ] goddamn horrible every
time I go to a place like Seattle in is
raining they're like you should have
been here last week is [ __ ] horrible
oh my gosh worse than this I move I was
[ __ ] worse than this I check it out
move hey real quick move if I grew up in
any one of those areas I'd [ __ ] I'd
[ __ ] my whole life to move in let's
see how does a great city it's a great
city however always wet it's a great
city
however it's like thoughts always wet so
yeah I I did my shows there they were
great see how the show sold out the
Spokane show sold out
it's a ching-ching in a bag in it dude
we gotta start playing the [ __ ] I
remember that [ __ ] you know how you
can hum any song except for a rap song
what's that [ __ ] song this song this
is the bag unit song you can't hum this
song try to hum this song playing link
the link blink blink blink mm hip hop is
only music you can't harm dude hey bag
unit
[Music]
what are those [ __ ] what even are
those did they make create instruments
for that song Blaine Blaine played I am
playing playing you know what you can't
hum either is the [ __ ] I need 50 cent
so I'm pretty much you can't hum that
what's that uh 21 questions playing
around plump lump lump lump lump lump
lump but by Bob limp limp limp la plum
plum
anyway dude bag unit I wish I'm a wallet
I'd flip it open and be like bag unit
we've been trailing you for years
you got no bags and anyway I I'm having
a good time dude I'm sick but that can't
[ __ ] set me down I'm not sick I had
allergies what's the difference really
dude
when your mucus see it [ __ ] sucks huh
people are just people just are like
wanting to shake your hand and I got you
gotta be like not I don't want to get
you I'm just [ __ ] BAM I got to do
that and then feeling like oh okay well
you're too cool huh nah man trying to
help you out man how about the [ __ ]
tank a sheep less 9 was isn't now he's
not gonna go to jail that's [ __ ]
amazing cuz he's a [ __ ] snitch dude I
love these rappers are just like [ __ ]
y'all down for my homies I'll kill
everybody from my homies arrive from my
mom [ __ ] and then it's like oh yeah
but you're going to jail I'd be like
okay it was him
you [ __ ] snitch ass [ __ ] and
he's gonna go into witness protection
protection he's gonna go to the witness
protection program
hey gonna get shot immediately he's got
a 6 9 on his forehead um he's got the
sawed guy on the tricycle on his cheek
gonna get caught
gonna get killed dude hey man you're
gonna die hey you've got [ __ ] rainbow
teeth plea deal
short sentence witness protection hey
they're gonna [ __ ] kill you
immediately you have a web on your neck
ah dude what's he gonna dress up in a
business suit and change the 69 to an 88
still a ham hey cuz are you [ __ ]
topology Sam fine no really what's on
your forehead 88 stupid what is you
stupid
you got the saw guy on your cheek no
what is that [ __ ] that's telling
Savalas I changed it I mean it's always
been telling Savalas
it's the scream mask okay cool
Hey sipar chief Ambon you're gonna
[ __ ] get shot immediately just put on
the whole saw mask I mean dude how about
having another face on your face hey
talk about being sad be who you are
don't put another face on your face
this kid's gonna get shot immediately
he's gonna be like this yeah okay it was
sign here all right cool all right Sonic
all right cool all right cool so you're
free to go we got to relocate you to
Florida all right cool get in the plane
all right
don't hello
[ __ ] Jason or whatever his new name
is gonna be would you like some peanuts
oh sure are you stupid
okay I'll get some peanuts for you here
you go and seats back to the table
you never [ __ ] flying far doesn't
please like Shh
boom okay the plane of course in the
plane he's just stupid all right where's
the cool Florida hey where's it where's
the baggage
[ __ ] turns out I was stupid the whole
time dude
yo how did you notice him oh he had a
[ __ ] 88 on his forehead
I mean did talk about a guy that [ __ ]
dug his own grave hey man get Doug hey
did when you were rapping instead of
doing that you were digging your digging
downward you were making the whole sea
get in it did instead of rapping and
making all those [ __ ] hits that you
said you were doing
y'all got a [ __ ] hit on I got a hit
in Spanish on [ __ ] American Bilbo are
you [ __ ] stupid instead of doing that
you were actually digging you're
actually digging a hole to get in what's
wrong man nobody's gonna learn to
there's give me another [ __ ] wrapper
that just does the same [ __ ] it's kind
of it I guess it's sad at what point is
it not sad anymore and then it's just
like you're doing it to yourself a lot
of guys have had fucked-up lives and you
still you make it do it and you're on
the straight and narrow but this guy
dude Bisbee buckles in the Midwest being
so gay how he says it
my TV's pop up in the Maybach band I
teach out of stunts it's crazy how
rappers really wrapped like a [ __ ]
like they're women or like a gay man
like they go shopping they talk about
diamonds and then they [ __ ] love
things you know ultimate Koda
but whatever dude me and my friend used
to do [ __ ] hip-hop lyrics go up to
the time and we used to do them like
newscasters and we were [ __ ]
so hard dude we'd be like my TV's pop up
in a make we'd be like my TV's pop up in
a Maybach Benz I'll teach you at a stunt
tonight at 11:00 dude I love our news is
like is broccoli bad for you tonight at
11:00 and then I want I'll just want it
to turn on at 11:00 and the news and
it'd just be like we're back no [ __ ]
dude we're back remember that thing we
asked you and the commercial break the
answer is no now here comes some [ __ ]
late-night TV that only old people watch
ding ding ding ding ding ding thank
bring anyway woman will have him alive
live on my app I'm a lapper oh man
that's interesting just can't believe
Reebok did a deal with a psycho tonight
at 11:00 I finna drop that so I suggest
you lay low anyway yeah dude he's gonna
go to he's gonna he snitched dude why
wouldn't you snitch you know these
rappers are all like dude I would never
snitch I'll Rob for my dog [ __ ] that
dude I'm not riding for my dog you know
what I'm doing getting out of the car
and snitching [ __ ] that dude
hey if you shoot somebody and I'm in
your gang I'm getting out of the car and
walking over to a cop and snitching I'm
telling him everything plus [ __ ] that oh
you're in a gang yet his gang life is
real life
cool guess what's real life being out of
prison he did it he did it um I'm a
point NASA [ __ ] if you kill
someone dude if you're in my family you
know how it tires like nothing's thicker
than blood you know it's thicker than
blood he did it
that I'm not going to jail [ __ ] ass he
did it
oh you'll reduce my sentence he did it
I'm the [ __ ] how do you get bags in
prison dude how do you go to Kalamazoo
and get [ __ ] bags if you're in San
Quentin he did it
[ __ ] that dude who did it the guy with
the rainbow hair who did it the guy with
the [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] who did
it I'm telling all but he might kill you
he did it yeah for real dude these
months these [ __ ] so weird like
being tough as a thing you know like
being a tough is being tough as a thing
my buddy said he was oh and if you're
Rush and forget it my buddy said he was
over at a Russian girl's house and he
was trying to like hook up with her and
she had a cat and he was allergic to
cats and he's like oh I gotta go because
you have a cat and I can't even like my
eyes are swollen and I'm like sniffling
and she was like you are weak huh and he
was like okay say yeah but you're weak
man huh
yeah see yeah I don't want my eyes
swollen more than my dick tonight
let's see yeah you know dude like what
I'm trying to get hard I'm trying to get
hard not [ __ ] make it hard not to
sneeze so bad joke dude somebody tweeted
me oh yeah be funny not [ __ ] funny
boy a sat on Twitter just be funny I'm
like do you want to go to a [ __ ] Shh
you want it you want jokes come to a
show pay for it loser
[Music]
dude you know [ __ ] puffs my bag up
[ __ ] you want jokes puff my bag up I
was too puffy gotten out of the back I'm
in the [ __ ] bag unit um hello you
know I don't know but that's crazy
though dude have you seen I'm talking
about I was talking about fashion I
guess I didn't even know who Carl Largo
is Karl Lagerfeld lager lager felt and
make up the felt partner is that his
real name la kerfeld la kerfeld
Lagerfeld and yeah he died I guess he
was in fashion I didn't really know I
don't know much about fashion but
everyone's pretending like they love
fashion now cuz he died and then also
Burberry put a [ __ ] a hoodie on
walking out someone who was walking down
the runway with a [ __ ] noose around
the neck oh hey that's not gonna work in
2019 Burberry huh hey man they were
probably they were probably like oh dude
fashion [ __ ] sucks dude put on a
shirt put on pants go get a coffee and
chill with a friend stop dressing like
you're in the goddamn 3046 it's so
ridiculous this [ __ ] any and I'm talking
about obviously look I'm a sneaker head
and [ __ ] as I got this [ __ ] on right now
I got the [ __ ] you know the Jordans
and [ __ ] I like fashion dude I wear cool
hip [ __ ] but relax dude if you're not
taking the piss if you're for real we're
in the [ __ ] and you're walking down some
runway relax man get out of here it's so
stupid dude it's really boring actually
is what it is you're not creative
you're just you're boring you know like
you're not you're just like a kid with
crayons you just drawn all over and moms
like good that's what it is that's what
you are if you set up one of those
runaway [ __ ] shows and
everyone's just walking around with like
some vest with one sleeve on it and your
dicks all out and you've got just pants
on from the knees down you just and
everyone's like yay good everyone's your
[ __ ] kid
you're a [ __ ] mom is what you are
you're a proud mom you're a proud mom
and you are the baby you're the kid
that's what you are yay you're not doing
anything man it's boring as [ __ ] it's
just like and Burberry put the noose
around the neck and they were like nah I
guess they didn't think or whatever or
they did think they were like we're
gonna make a statement about it or
whatever dude
you're [ __ ] boring dude you're a
[ __ ] boring company that can't make
[ __ ] the order that is nervous about
not making dope [ __ ] anymore so you're
trying to get a reaction you're boring
as [ __ ] dude I mean dude and then the
and then the person who spoke out about
it some model spoke out about it and she
was like I can't believe that Burberry
did this you were in the [ __ ] show
she's blaming the company and she walked
in the show
hey you culpable what dude what you were
stop complaining it's not their fault
it's your fault a model you're in the
show dude and then everyone's like wow
going to coming to her defense oh man
thank God for speaking up you were in
the show what that's like being [ __ ]
that's like being in the show taxi and
then being mad at the [ __ ] taxis ah
you did it you're in the show he did it
dude what are you talking about everyone
just wants to complain that's how you
know you
were in the show you walked in the show
and now you're on social media trying to
get attention about how the show was
irresponsible guess whose fault that was
yours
gunk now I just slammed you know it take
a walk into Denny's with me here's an
all-american grand slam backs
yeah I'm losing my mind whatever but
whatever everyone's as much as annoying
it is that Burberry made the [ __ ]
thing around with the news and of course
it was stupid the people who are trying
to bury Burberry for that they're just
as [ __ ] annoying the fashion is
fashion and you're supposed to break
boundaries and you're supposed to do
what you're going to do and you're
supposed to [ __ ] do whatever you want
to do and there's no rules
then that's what fashion is and if they
put a [ __ ] noose around the neck then
uh-oh you're gonna [ __ ] now play
victim and be mad about it well what
then who makes the [ __ ] rules [ __ ]
do I think it was stupid yeah I do
am I on social media talking about a
don't by Barberie now no by Burberry if
you want to [ __ ] buy Burberry
who gives a [ __ ] are they making suicide
fashionable yes is that bad yeah it's
bad it's not cool to kill yourself
obviously or maybe it's not obvious but
I'm [ __ ] telling you um yeah I do it
it's so the world we live in
Brown pamphlet man bro well my name
ma'am
but the
speaking of fashion the [ __ ] did you
see the Kawhi Leonard shoes have you
seen him one fire oh my dude they
literally are marketing boring it's so
crazy how he was nobody I mean he was
making a lot of money and he wasn't but
he wasn't a star until that laugh until
and then everyone's like who's this guy
and now he made a shoe that's s Sabourin
and it just says Kawhi Leonard on it
like there's no even like insignia or
cool [ __ ] that's the [ __ ] Kawhi Leonard
is the [ __ ] because he made a boring
shoe and he's marketing boredom regular
he's regular dude Wow Kawhi Leonard is
[ __ ] so regular it's unbelievable hey
man you did it you've you [ __ ]
marketed regular it's just crazy dude I
[Music]
gotta get those shoes it just says Kawhi
on one foot and then Leonard on the
other and then it's boring and it's New
Balance dude I don't know how that guy
he's like a genius more than we are
he [ __ ] is on another level he's just
like see that's what it is guys who just
are who they are that's [ __ ] dope and
then you got these fashion [ __ ]
that are just trying so hard to be a
[ __ ] to be talked about
just like and you got my [ __ ] like
Kawhi Leonard that just and makes the
most boring a shoe for New Balance I'm
telling you that guy's a hero in this
[ __ ] time of need
and he's gonna get [ __ ] bags
Burberry apologizes for featuring on the
deal with
I don't know man mmm but uh that's
[ __ ] crazy that that that he made
though she's got look at these shoes
anyway I can do ads here quit one of the
most important things we do for our
health everyday is brushing our teeth
yet most of us don't do it properly
equip is in a is a better electric
toothbrush created by dentists and
designers quip was designed to make
brushing your teeth more simple
affordable and even enjoyable sensitive
sonic vibrations for an effective clean
that's gentle on your sensitive gums
people brush too hard and some electric
toothbrushes are too abrasive built-in
two-minute timer pulses every 30 seconds
to remind you when you switch sides and
how to clean your whole mouth evenly
because 90% of us and me before quip we
don't brush we don't brush for a full
two minutes or don't clean evenly but
now I do thanks to quip brush heads are
automatically delivered on a dentist
recommended schedule every three months
for just five dollars a friendly
reminder when it's time for a refresh
and to stay committed to your oral
health you don't update your brushes
enough 75% of us use wore old worn-out
bristles that are ineffective but I love
quip and I have it at home and I use it
on the road it makes my mouth feel good
that's why I love quip and why they're
backed by over twenty thousand dental
professionals quip starts at just 25
dollars and if you go to get quick calm
/ Congrats right now you get your first
refill pack for free with a quip
electric toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at GE
tqu IP comm / congrats congratulations
is brought to you by cash app America's
favorite app with that name uh-huh dude
if I was at Thanksgiving and he was
[ __ ] laughing like that at Tamra how
would you saw a man no you're not
[ __ ] laughing like that anymore
do a regular laugh go out go outside get
a [ __ ] regular life will happen ah ha
ha ha what's this way man [ __ ] you're a
baby crying
um I know he's probably cool dude though
there's [ __ ] it I got you know what
I'm here's something I'm [ __ ] happy
about with me I talk about [ __ ] a
lot I I have a annoying there are I
wonder if you guys are like this too
exhausting about this about myself I
have like people that thoroughly annoy
the [ __ ] out of me that I [ __ ] la
like a lot I always find that to be
something where I'm like like I got some
friends that like are annoying is [ __ ]
to be around but I still really like
them is that does that count does that
count
babies do you not I mean do I like the
guy can you like somebody that you're
[ __ ] completely annoyed with all the
time or is that what did I say mutually
exclusive or will not Mitchell issues I
don't even know which one means what
but can you like somebody that you're
annoyed with most of the time I guess
you can right or is that love
maybe I just love them you know like if
your brother annoys the [ __ ] outta you
all the time maybe you love him if you
[ __ ] a store or around him
well maybe you like him I don't know I
haven't really thought this through but
that's what this podcast is Jesus you
know sharing ideas and getting sucked in
[ __ ] but I just don't know I was think
about this one Graham particularly he
was writing me asking me all sorts of
questions that was so [ __ ] super
annoying and the cycle is man you know
even though I have lots of time to
myself cuz sometimes I'm on planes
[ __ ] do it I don't want to answer you
but I do maybe you know Bobby leaves a
little like that like he's he doesn't
text me back a noise a [ __ ] out of me
and I like him that's different I'm
talking about person who's like like
Bobby Lee doesn't make me roll my eyes
people that are just [ __ ] in your
face and trying to be [ __ ] funny and
like I oh man but you like them is that
what I'm like
[ __ ] maybe I headed some new dates and I
think the merch is restocked - you got
that dent list 2020 [ __ ] mm-hmm did I
get new dates I got a what he calls on
on I got presale or some [ __ ] Edmonton
Fargo Victoria BC there we go
Sioux Falls South Dakota why am I going
there Des Moines Iowa but these are all
places
now we're going babies and I'm gonna go
and I'm gonna bring the [ __ ]
follow-the-leader tour there because I'm
gonna be performing there and I like
doing it so what else are we talking
about here what else happened this week
I just have to go to [ __ ] Toronto and
area next week Hamilton or whatever it's
just so cold man I'm sick and tired of
this cold it's even called in LA dude
it's like a raining and [ __ ] you see all
these [ __ ] Lant like landslides all
this down the hill like mud just trying
to drive over the [ __ ] drive over rocks
and [ __ ] dude he's crazy what happens to
LA when it rains a lot it's like the
city was just not built for it all wants
to go outside anyway I don't know but
you want to do let's do let's do this
right now
let's do either miss connect let's do
Twitter do we have Twitter questions no
you want to do miss connections and then
this way we'll do miss connections and
then we're doing it we're gonna do a
little bit differently though so we're
gonna do a little bit earlier and we're
also doing the [ __ ] Miami the Miami
edition because we thought why not do
Miami addition because Miami is [ __ ]
insane dude I'm talking about
mom is the most insane [ __ ] place in
the world maybe
maybe maybe so we're going to Miami to
do the Miss connections here pull some
Bella's pull some up we're here we go
Miami miss connection where are all
here's the subject where are here's the
subject where are all the new room Asajj
girls no I don't know what neuro is but
I'm gonna [ __ ] what is new row do I
have to look this up or am I gonna not
even like it one fire put up something I
don't even know just pull it up
oh is that what the oil oh yeah did the
whole body massage with the but isn't
that just regular massages is it sexual
oh it's very sexual or the up okay and
very sexual you know why because the
first thing that came up wasn't YouTube
it was wet lubricant tube hey men I mean
sick appearing YouTube I mean everything
is tube nuru massage dude will you just
get a regular massage with so much oil
just so gross and then you get [ __ ]
stroked man I bet that feels [ __ ]
crazy amazing dude I bet your whole
body's just like oh I bet you're [ __ ]
just rubbing all over just like oh god I
bet you dude if I got a new room massage
I would for sure [ __ ] and I would just
be like I'm sorry and they'd be like
it's okay it's a new room massage it
happens a lot
anyway the body of this is such a shame
these girls have nowhere to post anymore
but I am here in need your service what
do you mean go to [ __ ] wet lubricant
tube comm wet lubricant dude tube calm
man that's what I think takashi-san
fines gonna be right now a new nuru
massage girl just like this
nuru massage in and they're like yo we
do my penis and he's like of course I am
what the [ __ ] is you stupid uh here we
go
saw you at Walgreens Miami
dude it's always so weird to me that
like even though like Miami is Miami
there's still Walgreens and [ __ ] you
know like in like Vegas when you go to
like pop and ass places that there's
still like a [ __ ] one-hour photo
there you know also how are one-hour
photo place is still in business
everyone has a [ __ ] photo Development
Center in their goddamn phone ah that's
for sure if you if there's a one-hour
photo place in in LA it's for sure a
front for like Russian Russian selling
cocaine saw you at Walgreens Miami long
shot as many here said but worth trying
for sure saw you at the store you were
waiting to pick up your prescription
spoke with you briefly outside and
regretting not taking your number if you
see this let me know what car you're
driving and what you were wearing that
day so creepy do not contact me with son
solicited services or offers I mean
asking so much information you know
maybe he's just trying to get me to make
sure it's her I guess to prove it like
somebody would just see this thing and
then just be like oh dude that guy
sounds hot he was outlaw greens hey it
was me let's [ __ ] do a neuro massage
why did they use so much oil dude what a
waste
so wastin man I I what are you doing at
Walgreens in Miami
dude go to Miami and only party okay get
your [ __ ] first then go to Miami
maybe he got sick though and he was
going to get some [ __ ] medication
dude Miami is insane
when I go to Miami I'm always like
already eyed it's like Vegas dude when
you go there you're like keg I'll leave
you get there you could step outside
7,000 degrees in the summer okay I gotta
leave all muscular guys that are wider
than they are tall okay gotta leave they
did all look like that [ __ ] I'm such
a [ __ ] no I love it in that video yes
if so old guy I'm such a [ __ ] how I
said so old white guy you're such a
[ __ ] uh I love it
this years no no ma'am
Harry young guy downtown serve a glitz a
specific at the same time you were a
young and very hairy guy oh this guy's
not writing any books huh you were a
young and very hairy guy legs excetera
uh you know I like how he's so specific
but then also still ends it with et
cetera like the Vegas way you could end
something you were a young and very
hairy guy legs etc oh you mean like
shoulders arms [ __ ] everything okay
go we used to hook up all the time I
would pick you up from college would
love to connector looking for someone
similar m4m do not contact me
unsolicited services or offers dude why
do these guys not have anybody's number
that's the weirdest part to me don't who
deletes do you delete numbers I just
probably have every number I've ever had
in my life somewhere I don't know that's
why you know when somebody is like oh
yeah don't have your [ __ ] number
anymore I got a new phone that's such
[ __ ] now what is this [ __ ] in 1999
you deleted the number cuz you [ __ ]
hate me it's okay but it happened um
yeah man also this is a good one from
Miami here cuz you know I haven't read
this one yet but you know it's like lead
with it this is the subject looking to
rent a boat for two hours hey man it's
definitely gonna turn sexual so lead
with that okay all right hello whoever
reads this I'm looking to rent a small
paddle boat not the one with the wheel
but the one you have to paddle with a
large stick you know what I mean uh
nothing
see just big enough for two people
looking to take my wife on a nice
romantic dinner he's got to come to [ __ ]
is just say or romantic dinner on
Valentine's while the boat just sails
calmly and we hopefully don't die huh if
you have inflatable jackets every grid
also because I don't know how to swim
what the [ __ ]
we're both very polite and educated
people who will take care of your boat
ah this is the most sideways way to talk
about sex we just haven't gotten on a
damn boat since we've been here in Miami
okay man we don't know how long you've
been there be a pal and rent us your
boat if you can't trust us with your
boat you can't stare at us from afar
what dude why rent us your boat because
we're not rich enough to buy a boat yet
I love my wife and want to surprise her
dinner dinner will be as cliche as you
can imagine it okay thank you only
serious inquiries only because everyone
adds that at the end of this Craigslist
post did not contact me just unsolicited
services offers what the [ __ ] is this
guy talking about about or is he talking
about [ __ ] busting a nut yeah it's on
misconnections hey dude got a boat dude
this is the weirdest [ __ ] also just two
hours you know hello to whoever reads
this post it on [ __ ] boats wanted
calm you know post it on lubricant tube
calm but what the [ __ ] why is it on
misconnections wow man people are so
[ __ ] weird I can't stand when people
write anything that begins with hey no
you probably won't see this but hey
nobody will see this I'm sure
hey maybe nobody will see this but
[ __ ] so insecure plus you never have
to write that because the people who
don't see it
aren't going to see that the people who
are reading it that is a moot point too
so you never have to say that that's
like saying blah blah blah blah - lolly
puta just [ __ ] write what you're
gonna write dude I get DMS and [ __ ]
5% of them is you probably never see
this but and if I see that in the header
I never click in it so you [ __ ] yourself
man there's rules don't start a [ __ ]
like that that's so insecure to start a
message like hey if I'm not gonna see
this but bro you matter or not the
[ __ ] going on do you embed our or not
I hate to use the words of Sam paunchy
fact time but the [ __ ] is you stupid why
is it no space in my nose I don't know
I'm loopy today what was that idiot
one fire one fire [ __ ] tried to
FaceTime me during the show I say nah
nah but we know how it goes dude I mean
you try to [ __ ] FaceTime me in the
middle of my show did we used to make a
joke about how because my uncle Richard
laughs like this me and my uncle always
me and my brother always talking about
that and Tupac talks like this yeah so
we used to see that we always see that
uh my uncle Richard used to say that he
last like Tupac which is so [ __ ] dumb
it was also such a stretch and now it'll
text me about that so that's cool man
good yay-yay one time I'm not gonna say
who it is in my family but there was a
party for a kid and and for one of the
kids in our family and he came out once
dude I can't believe this this is
weird this actually happened but this
really did actually happen the kid came
out of he was like playing with the
other kids and his hair was all messed
up and one of the adults in our family I
think I don't know if he was actually in
our family or like extended family or
what he looked at his hair and in front
of so many adults he said what you get
right he's 12
what you get right
I mean we were there my jaw dropped I
was [ __ ] 20 how did you say that to a
kid kids like what's rape huh
my brother and I [ __ ] always and for
some reason over time it turned from
because the guy kind of sounded like
this that's how the adult sounded and
when we and when he said he said what
you get right and we changed up what you
get right and then we kept on oh and
we'll always forget wojtek's what get
dude how dumb is or how dumb are
families the trajectory of what you get
raped
is so dumb dude [ __ ] yeah I love
families man you think I give a [ __ ]
I love families man brain pain pain pain
pain pain pain dude families are the
[ __ ] hey my mom is Al Pacino do remember
when I said that last time cuz she's
more like cuz Al Pacino gets so much
like Al Pacino as he gets older and
older
he just gets more and more Al Pacino my
mom gets more my mom and your mom gets
more and more your mom if somebody
doesn't watch out the old you get the
more like you you get and somebody
[ __ ] made a meme and my mom and I'll
put her face on the opportunity my mom
and it you think my [ __ ] mom wants to
see that [ __ ] don't tag my mom in the
[ __ ] meme trying to out here getting
bags and I got a deal with some
collateral damage dude my [ __ ] put my
mom's face on Al Pacino now she's got to
be like why is my face on Al Pacino bro
the [ __ ] come on think about it
what are you Burberry [ __ ] out of here
what are you doing dude
Oh God like like Napoleon Dynamite
movies funny what's up with jussie
Smollett and buy that the only thing I'm
talking about is why is his name not
Jesse that's like that Pulte [ __ ] change
one letter in the [ __ ] it's a handsome
ass [ __ ] but he shaves his
mustache and leaves his beard like he's
[ __ ] Abe Lincoln no hey man are you
the 16th president no grow your stache
out or shave the beard - hey Jesse what
the [ __ ] are you doing why'd you [ __ ]
hire two guys from Mad Cobra to come
beat you up those guys are the most
muscle guys of all time dude this guy
lied about the [ __ ] hired two guys first
of all paid him thirty five hundred
dollars each
till my it's just I bet the guys would
have done it for free that'll be like oh
you're the [ __ ] famous guy cool yeah
let's do it
they rehearsed it oh it's not a [ __ ]
musical just got there and beat them up
pretend dude such a whacko [ __ ] thing
to do Jesse um
crush hey what's your name my name is
crusts D'Elia
beat me up here's $3,500 guys from Mad
Cobra dude those guys look so much like
they [ __ ] are huge huge reggae stars
the people the guys who beat up jussie
Smollett looks so much like [ __ ] huge
Reggie reggae stars flakes 0.006 uh got
paid $3,500 to beat up Jesse flex time -
over six made us rehearse it one time
and do for real flex time the other six
just see Smollett let us beat him up we
took the money
ah then we got caught
then we told the [ __ ] cops we don't
care we're in over our heads ah we
stitch immediately we look the same
flexor we're so muscular why did they
pick us we saw identifiable flakes they
said we had mega hats on but we're two
black guys why would we do that
flakes huh why would we call him the
n-word if we are both black of lexa this
does not make sense since the picture of
them at Runyon Canyon that they use from
TMZ with puka shells on in an open
hoodie holding a [ __ ] each other like
they're literally took the picture of
why you why are you talking about huh
yeah yeah did you guys beat up Jesse
Smollett who are you talking about yeah
it's illegal
yeah although he paid us flex time the
other six can we finish the hike right
now this is easy we do it with weights
on because we're so [ __ ] muscular
flex we go up Runyon Canyon this is
easier than going on down the aisles and
target flags are a boobies Rd cops our
ABS our dick up stood they pop out dude
I mean the guys I can't believe this
whole [ __ ] mess look with the steam
room ah I mean there we there's the guys
he picked pick white guys you [ __ ]
idiot pick Asians pick [ __ ]
armadillos you picked black guys you
picked black guys and you said that they
were yelling out Trump nation No
and Jesse dude dude it's just
unbelievable how [ __ ] stupid dishes
[ __ ] as if it's for real I mean I just
can't believe it would have done it for
a G to negotiate better we know you've
got money cuz you're on a hit dude I
would have step backwards for all the
victims
[ __ ] this is why you can't believe
everybody pure lie why would you [ __ ]
make it up why would people make it up
[ __ ] justice Millette dude
that's why because as [ __ ] and are
you saying there aren't insane people
out there that's what you're saying
Oh believe the victims oh oh so you're
saying there's not insane people out
there that's what you're saying why
wouldn't you make [ __ ] up this [ __ ]
guy for what this guy's never gonna work
again it doesn't even matter
Wow
cardi B he said he feel like you [ __ ]
I feel like he [ __ ] up Black History
Month broke goddamn yeah no [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] what it would it what a dick
I mean the guys he picked is so funny
the guys he picked the guys don't have a
care in the world yeah we do it for
$3,500 yeah and then the cops were like
did you do it and were like yeah I mean
they're probably don't they're probably
not Jamaican they look [ __ ] you're
making though they look like they're
just funnier for some reason weren't
they extras in the show too like what
are you doing dude outsource it Wow
here's Ola Oh sundar yo man tied to
justice Millette case on Empire wow dude
just allow money to hire some guys to do
some [ __ ] to me not like beat me up cuz
that would be too much but maybe like
vandalize the comedy club when I'm there
and I'll be like I was a victim and I
paid him two hundred and ten dollars
each dude I just can't believe that also
news outlets are like and they say they
aren't racist so why would they scream
out the n-word to him but what dude
everywhere I read that's what they're
saying and they're not addressing to the
the fact they're not addressing the fact
that these guys are not racist and it
wasn't a racially charged crime because
they were the same race what how are you
saying what what like oh they're not
they say they're not racist though know
what yeah okay they're black he's black
huh Wow dude I don't know man but it's
like I can't wait till more [ __ ] comes
out about it
Empire I've never I haven't even seen
that show isn't that the one with the
hustle and flow guy what's that guy's
name Terrence Howard he came up to me
once at the Comedy Store and he was like
hey man after my show it is kind of a
brag just so you know he was like hey
man I just got to tell you I came to see
you last week at The Comedy Store and I
came tonight again because I wanted to
tell you that I was gonna do Oprah and I
was a little like unsure about what I
was gonna say and because it's a big
audience and all that and I saw you do
stand-up and that [ __ ] made me think you
gave me the confidence to go out there
and just do that [ __ ] and then I went
out there and did it so I just wanted to
tell you that
and I was like wow thanks that means a
lot coming from you
you know I mean he said [ __ ] real
talented actor and he was like yeah I
just wanted to let you know that I was
like damn that [ __ ] made me feel good
I don't see his Oprah thing but he was
happy with it so hey glad to help out I
bet that guy is I bet
Terrence Howard is so good in bed I bet
he's so [ __ ] good in bed I bet if all
the chips fell if there was a [ __ ]
contest that in the world and I'm
talking in the world you know like there
would probably be some like Italian guy
from like Toscana in like that's from a
vineyard you know that like would come
in number one and then probably some
buddy from like that lives in it in an
igloo in like Alaska or Antarctica
[ __ ] is like to probably to three and
two and three are like because that's
all because they're so cold that they're
just always [ __ ] our ice fish in
anyway they're like after they've done
ice fishing they're like okay I got a
[ __ ] you know then there's gotta be like
for sure somebody from the Dominican
Republic that is just number four that
just kills it because they never stop
dancing and they just like they like
they like use that for their sex moves
and and women are just like I don't know
how he does it and he's just like it's
just because of the way I move I take it
from the dance floor to the thing and
then number five is Terrence Howard and
you can tell because of the way he acts
that's how good of an actor he is and he
just uses his acting while he's like
thrusting and I guarantee it's so sexy
cuz he has sex like he's not even doing
it like he's just like
like that's how he has sex and the girls
just like oh my god it's weird but I'm
so into it and he's just never had sex
without a shirt on and he's just and
then right before he busts in that he
says what are we doing after this and
the girls just like oh my god that was
the sexiest thing I've ever and his pant
and he just pulls up his pants because
they're already around his ankles he
never got naked and [ __ ] ever he's had
a ball often he's wearing a blade but
like a two layers like he's got the
shirt on and then a blazer or some [ __ ]
and he's just and he's got earrings and
like a lot like he just straight-up
wears all the [ __ ] when he [ __ ] and
it's and he's number five and if there
was a [ __ ] off he'd be number five and
number six would be a woman and because
the top five [ __ ] are guys I'm sure
because they have to be because women
don't have to be women can just lay
there because they're beautiful but guys
got to do it so I'm counting women in
this men and women in the world if there
was a [ __ ] off Terrence Howard comes in
fifth it goes like this an Italian guy
that comes from Toscana
from a vineyard then to Eskimos then
somebody from the Dominican Republic
that dances all the time and then
Terrence Howard top five [ __ ] swear
to God then six is a woman will do a mom
or will do one more oh and there may be
seven and eight are the [ __ ] guys
that robbed Jesse Smollett but you have
to pay them married me this is another
one here we go in in misconnection
married man Cuban oh wow this is like a
[ __ ] this is this one's done like a
would it call it one of those haikus hi
next line Mike next line married man hi
Mike a married man looking to chat with
within oh man I love how there's always
so many typos hi Mike married man
looking to chat with indiscreet person
looking for a good park in Kendall no
drama no games Cuban looking for friends
let's talk do not contact me with
unsolicited
Scizor offers dude wise is written in
haiku form dude so weird married man
Cuban so Miami so Miami Wow
well dude let's wrap this up man that
was a fun one hey dogs stop barking my
dog's bark so much I'm at cool all right
so uh download the cash app for free on
the App Store or Google Play market
mm-hmm
thank you you guys are the best we love
you babies support the show by buying
merch at store Chris D'Elia calm we love
the support I see you out there with
your wouldn't make a dent shirts and
your dent list 2020 hoodies and your
[ __ ] babies merch and all that [ __ ]
it's awesome follow the store on twitter
at chris d'elia store subscribe to the
youtube channel those come out the
videos come out a day later subscribe
rate and review the show tweet me by
using the handle congrats pod or by
using the hashtag congratulations pod
video episodes go up a day after the
audio podcasts already said that watch
my episode of comedians of the world
non-stop and watch man on fire
incorrigible or white male black comic
on Comedy Central and like it or
whatever the hell they do like in [ __ ]
anyway that's it we got new dates on
sale this Friday so be ready they're
gonna sell out quick Des Moines Iowa
Sioux Falls South Dakota Fargo North
Dakota Edmonton Alberta and Victoria BC
I'm coming to Oakland California and
Newport News and Phoenix and Tucson in
Santa Fe New Mexico and Albuquerque
anyway these are all the place places
I'm playing all the place I'm playing
and a bunch of the ones that Chris
they're calm so thanks Dell no map doc
typing Krista Leah at the app store and
you guys are the best my babies and
remember keep
[Music]